hey everybody new Game of Thrones
trailer let's break it down there's a
new round of the giveaway - all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so what is
this talk about salsa saying the lone
wolf dies but the pack survives it
sounds like little fingers speaking to
her in the trailer teaching her to fight
battles in her mind while Jon Snow is
fighting the real physical battles
trying to form the Alliance in the north
and then you see this backdrop of all
the wars happening across Westeros so it
gets really crazy later in the trailer
let's just go through this shot by shot
this is nuts
you see the gate opening up at the wall
Jon Snow in the wildlings stepping out
into the frozen north we get a shot of
the Lannister controlled King's Landing
it looks like the peasants aren't too
happy if you remember way back during
season two they had that big Joffrey
riot where they killed one of the great
septons and they almost carried Sansa
off so she looks like she's back down in
the black cells where she's keeping
septa unella I know we've seen a lot of
the mountain but it's gonna be really
grisly just to think about the things
that they've been doing to her down
there more of Daenerys Landing at
Dragonstone and then walking around the
map table Arya slowly making her way
back to Winterfell this looks like
Jamie's still at King's Landing walking
around the battlements Littlefinger back
in the crypts this is a repeated shot
from the last trailer they keep talking
about battles as people are sharpening
their blades so just people preparing
for war and even though there's going to
be a lot of war this season I think
we're expecting season 8 to be like a
six episode long battle like every
single episode
Daenerys walking on the beach on
Dragonstone the cool thing about this
the way they shot this you can see this
outline of what looks like a dragon
edged in the rock here it's just the
natural formation of the rocks but I
love the imagery she's literally walking
into a dragon as she's walking into
Dragonstone that Jon Snow voiceover is
also very apropos - he's talking about
banding together to fight common enemy
he's talking about Robert's rebellion
fighting the Targaryen 's but in reality
because they cut all of the night king
and the White Walkers into this trailer
you're really thinking about everyone in
Westeros banding together to fight their
common enemy because
enemy is real and then they get all the
shots of the White Walkers but this is
Daenerys pulling down Stannis's banner
as she walks in we finally get a better
shot of the dragons we've only seen
drogon in the previous trailer but this
is just such a beautiful look at
Dragonstone I love this worried
concerned look on Tyrians face shot a
Theon with the Greyjoy battles there's a
couple more big Greyjoy shots in this
trailer to grey worm looking like he's
getting ready to assault Casterly Rock
suddenly you remember that story that
tyrion told about how his father gave
him the task of fixing the plumbing in
Casterly Rock so the waste would have
below like Lannister gold out of their
minds this looks like their infiltration
point if you look at the map here
Lannisport Casterly Rock are right here
so they probably sailed into this bay
pod and Brienne at Winterfell we had a
shot of them training in that last
behind-the-scenes trailer so it looks
like pause trying to get better pray and
just kicking the crap out of him in a
love of the jump to the shot of the
hound way up in the frozen north so he's
definitely part of Jon Snow's band like
when you see them all circled up here
you see them running during different
parts of the trailer fighting with the
night king they're standing here well
looks like the fist of the first men he
along with beric Dondarrion and the
blaming sword that you saw Stannis use
you could think of it as azor Ahai but I
love the way that it just lights up on
command he doesn't stick it into fire it
literally just lights up this shot of
the unsullied being taken down by arrows
looks like it's connected to the shot of
Jamie on the field with the archers just
more the unsullied charging the
Lannister infantrymen more the Greyjoy
battle as they're burning each other
ships and then so many of you been
asking me when is brand finally going to
fly this is how bran is flying he's
flying over the army of the Dead looking
at the night king so you see the eye of
the crow sort of switched so you can
tell that he's Ward into it that's what
the three-eyed Raven meant when he said
that you will fly someday and then you
see the night king notices him so he can
sense brands presence this shot of brand
here actually makes it look like he's at
Winterfell in this wheelchair with Davos
here so this might be connected to Sansa
him telling everyone about Jon Snow's
heritage so it might be from before Jon
Snow goes up to the wall or it could be
connected to this shot of brand warding
all the Ravens
over the army of the Dead and just for
the record even though he does have the
flaming sword I do not think that he's a
Zora hi but remember in the books how he
gave his last kiss of life to Lady
Stoneheart
he's been resurrected six times he had
like one more to go he gave that last
one to Lady Stoneheart
maybe he'll do the same thing up north
of the wall because Sansa is talking
about the lone wolf died so maybe he'll
give the kiss of life to Jon Snow this
season we get all these gray Joyce ships
making their way into Blackwater Bay
just reminding you of the Blackwater
episode this time they might not have as
much wildfire so it'll be interesting to
see how they deal with that the
unsullied in formation getting ready to
assault Casterly Rock so this looks like
it's connected to that shot of grey
worms sneaking beneath Casterly Rock so
that they could get a strike force in so
they can get the regular army through
Daenerys on the battlements at
Dragonstone Jaime riding across a field
of fire it looks like Drogo after the
archers took down some of the unsullied
drogon rode in and just roasted the
entire battlefield field of fire style
during Aegon's conquest so there's a lot
of parallels for Aegon's conquest in
season seven just more the Greyjoy
battle blowing the crap out of each
other
and then all over Westeros the battles
get cranked up you see torment taking a
swing at the army of the Dead
you see drogon riding ahead of the
Dothraki bloodrider 'he's you see Theon
and Yara entering their battle that's
connected to all those ships blowing up
really awesome looking lannister
infantrymen that have absolutely no idea
what's coming for them and this is
probably one of my favorite shots of the
trailer what looks like the fist of the
first men with Jon Snow beric Dondarrion
and it looks like torment just getting
assaulted by the army of the Dead miss
and I and grey worm action if you're a
big fan of their relationship I know a
lot of people make comments about what
the mechanics of this relationship are
going to be because he's been cut that's
the whole idea that he's unsullied and
you might not be able to tell by looking
at this but this is finally Jon Snow at
Dragonstone you can tell by the rock
formations in the background so this has
got to be from at least episode two
three four however fast you think he's
going to make a beeline for Dragonstone
to treat with Daenerys Jon Snow vs.
White Walkers Brown - with long claw
even though this looks like it could be
white
Walker's I think this is actually from
the drogon battle after he's lit the
field up like you have all these
soldiers riding through the field up
fire back on the beach at Dragonstone
and this actually looks like our first
legit shot of euron greyjoy just having
it out with Tiana and Yara's men and
this here this actually looks like so
much fun so this is a dragon stone with
drogue on looking down which is probably
what Tyrion is looking up at really
worried we actually got some behind the
scenes for this you see Tyrion sort of
scanning his eyes around at this big
green screen thing as it's looking at
him while it looks like he's getting
ready to crap his pants this shot looks
like it could be Jon Snow as Sansa says
the lone wolf dies but the pack survives
but remember there are a number of
people that are dressed up and furs so
trailers always a bit misleading this
could even be Mira riding on horseback
but I love this shot here of Jon Snow
with Longclaw that reminds you of
episode 9 battle of the bastards as he
was being charged down by all those
Bolton's on horseback so it's sort of a
mirror for that except this time he has
the army of the Dead that's charging him
so he can just cross our fingers and
hope that a dragon will arrive in time
to save him let me know in the comments
what's your favorite part of the trailer
and what do you think about the idea of
little fingers of voice over to Sansa
about her fighting battles in the mind
in her coming to the conclusion that the
lone wolf very clearly talking about jon
snow dies but the pack survives and what
that says about their relationship this
season that just sounds crazy but I have
a couple more Game of Thrones videos
planned for later this week and I'll say
congratulations to Tom oh you're the
latest giveaway winner leave all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments below but you can click here
for all the other behind the scenes
videos and you can click here for all my
other season 7 videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight